okay 2100 and a waltz
let's go with the 184 i'm in an
aggressive mood
e4 g6 all right so that's the modern
i've played this with black quite a bit
in the speed run
this time we're on the white side of it
and
i mean there's a million systems that
you can play
um a million effective systems that you
can play but i'm gonna do something very
positional today
one line that really flies under the
radar against the perk of the modern is
this move pawn to c3
okay he instantly goes c5 which i think
is actually a mistake
uh against c3 because
i'll explain this move after the game
but one of the benefits of the move c3
is that queen a5 is no longer check so
we i believe we can just take the pawn
here and generally the response to this
is queen a5 check
[Music]
uh or queen a5 if the knight is on c3
but here he's going to have a hard time
recovering the pawn
okay so knight f6 obviously we need to
defend this pawn if we push it
actually maybe we can push it um
what happens if we push the pawn so
where's the knight going to go tonight's
going to go to e4 right
now it's gonna go to e4
and
then i think we can actually try to win
the knight let's go e5 let's see what
happens
let's try to go for maximum here
yeah bishop d3 was originally planned
okay he goes back to g8
now how should we go about defending the
spawn obviously we should defend it
what do you guys think we should do
i think there's a couple of cool a
couple of possible moves
now i think most people
probably are thinking about the move
knight f3 right i mean why don't we
defend develop the knight and
simultaneously protect the pawn but
knight f3 has a bit of a downside
which is that the pawn remains kind of
loose in knight f3 knight c6
and the pawn remains loose the move f4
would secure the pawn permanently
but the downside of f4 is that it kind
of weakens the king side right so this
is largely a matter of taste i think
both knight f3 bishop uh knight f3 and
pawn f4 are solid reasonable moves but
since we're trying to play a little bit
more positionally here we're going to go
with the developmental approach knight
f3
worst comes to worst if we lose the pawn
then we lose the damn pawn i mean that's
not that bad
all right so
which of these pawns
do we want to defend well
it's an interesting question um
because
and actually i think knight f3 was an
inaccuracy
or can we can we defend both of them
so if we defend the pawn on c5 if we
play bishop e3
then black will play knight c6 and black
will have three attackers on the pawn
and we'll only have one defender so
we're going to end up losing that pawn
now
try to think a little bit outside the
box are there any ways that we can
defend both pawns at the same time
well we can send in the cavalry we can
do queen d4 we can do queen d5 which of
those moves is better well one of them
uh when you develop your queen this
early you got to be extremely cautious
and hear queen d5 is much better because
after queen d4 black would have played
knight c6 with tempo
alright so this is a move you got to be
incredibly careful about playing
now we can go bishop f4 and defend the
pawn again
and i think a lot of you guys are
probably thinking well what about e6
isn't this move bad because of e6 but
i'll talk about that after the game he
goes f6
and um
i think that's a blunder so let's
calculate
let's calculate e takes f6
right
oh but knight takes f6 very nice idea by
black i don't know if he even saw this
he takes f6 he goes knight takes f6
and he counter attacks our queen
now that doesn't mean we don't want to
play e takes f6 maybe we do but i i
didn't see that initially
let's try to find the maximum here what
are the alternatives the alternative is
to play bishop c4
and then oh i think we have something
very cool there let's go bishop c4
one move threat but it's a great threat
and it also develops the bishop so this
isn't one move throughout itus you're
actually accomplishing something with
the development move
now i think
is the time for e takes f6
i actually think that taking on f6 now
is going to be
much better than taking on the previous
move
but i have to calculate
yeah
okay so there's a lot going on there's a
lot to unpack
and i'll do part of that after the game
but
start asking yourselves okay goes queen
takes f4
now what was my idea here
what does white do aren't we just losing
no we're not losing we can take g7
and if he takes our queen we take his
queen and we attack the knights
simultaneously which is really important
there's also a check on c1 that has to
be accounted for
in some of these positions if this
knight was not hanging we wouldn't even
necessarily go for this now we're just
up a full rook
this is this is game over actually
this is just game over
wow that was really interesting a lot to
unpack after the game here i think
there's a couple of pretty instructive
points 97
but first let's finish the game in style
let's make sure we don't give him any
chances
okay now
when the position changes this
drastically this quickly you need to
kind of reassess what the threats are
now obviously we're completely winning
but we've got to be actually very very
careful
um
what would we do well what are the
threats the first threat is for him to
take the bishop the second threat is
queen c1 queen c1 being the the more
annoying of the two threats
and
you may come up with the idea of going
bishop e2 or bishop b3
in order to meet queen c1 check with
bishop d1 but don't stop calculating
there i believe that that is a mistake
can somebody tell me why
why is it a mistake to cover the check
on d1
because b2 falls at the end of that line
black takes b2 and that rook on a1 is
going to be trapped
all right
um so that's a classic example of tunnel
vision at a higher level right queen c1
it's easy to tunnel vision that move and
think it only attacks the rock but it
also attacks b2
all right so
we have basically decided that we have
to do something against this threat so
one very prudent move here would be just
a castle castling would be an excellent
move we would give up the bishop but we
would still be up in exchange and
obviously black's king is completely
busted
but we also have a fancier move a lot of
you guys are noticing
a fancier move that i think may win the
game on the spot
and that is the move bishop takes d5
the way that this move works is that
after queen c1 check we simply bring the
king up to e2
if in that position the queen captures
b2 we can cover that check with the
knight connecting the rock
simultaneously
if the queen captures the rook on h1
then the queen is out of the game and we
take that knight on g8 with a
devastating attack
okay hopefully most of you guys followed
that line
now the way i saw bishop d5 is that i
understood that when two knights defend
each other that's a very delicate and
oftentimes
fragile construction and you can
easily overload one of these knights
queen takes h1 is going to happen and
then we take on g8 and essentially it's
over
knight takes queen takes
all right so
we have time here we're not in a rush
black is not getting his pieces out
anytime soon
i mean we can start by taking the pawn
but i don't even think we need to let's
give him a check on g7
and how to win such positions well as i
often say you have to reverse engineer
the win
um
we have to figure out where we want the
queen to go
um in order to maximize our attacking
chances so think about where
you know how which pathway do we take
with the queen also
the king might escape potentially to b8
so the best thing to do is find a way to
keep the king confined to the center
yeah queen to d6 so a lot of you are
seeing this queen fa queen d6
then the king has to keep him keep
itself in the center and we have an
easier time
since it's not a moving target
now the time has come clearly to involve
our knight
we double check that no checks are
threatened
and we just need to figure out where
this knight actually belongs
well let's think about that for a second
notice that the pawn on d7 is pinned
so again rather than thinking about all
of the moves simultaneously try to
figure out what the target square is for
the knight the target square is e6 if we
give a check on e6 the king moves and we
made him on fa so either knight d4 or
probably even better is to play knight
g5 this just seems more
aggressive
this is gonna probably force king e8 but
then clearly mate is at hand queen c1
check
and checkmate on f8
wow 21 moves or 22 moves but a lot
happened there
let's unpack
okay
so
bishop g7
is the modern
and the move c3 is definitely not the
most popular
most people just develop the knight
but it's a line favored by a lot of good
positional players like kamsky tibiakov
very positional gm's like to play c3
the idea is simple you're building upon
chance that the bishop is biting on
granite
what is the downside of such a move well
the downside is that the knight can't
develop itself to c3 but it could
develop to d2
so generally what happens in this line
black plays d6
white white puts a bishop on d3 the
knight on f3
and you get a position like this which
is slightly better for white this this
line does give a slight advantage you
develop the bishop and then you put the
knight on d2
and again the idea is to take this
bishop out of the game
sort of
get it to
bite bite on on these pawns
um so just just a line to consider
against the modern
a c5
is uh was a bad pre move he was
expecting knight c3 and here c5 actually
is a viable line
the point here is that
bishop takes c3 is threatened as well as
queen takes c5 but if we compare that to
this position queen a5 is no longer
effective because
this is not thread we can just play
bishop b3 and keep the pawn
okay so knight f6 and e5
i think the more testing move would have
been 94.
and here we have to be very precise
but i believe that we can win a piece
who sees the best move
and if you were following close
attention to the game then you should
find this move pretty quickly
the knight wants to capture c5 so can we
defend that pawn with tempo
can we defend that pawn with tempo
so
i have something really cool to show you
there are two ways to defend the pawn
with tempo
queen d4 and queen d5 now in the game
you guys will remember that queen d5 was
the better move
but in this position and i just verified
this with the engine actually queen d4
is the better move why is that
well let's understand what happens after
queen d4 and queen d5 and compare
the knight is attacked it has no squares
this is covered
this is covered
this looks clever because white can't
take with the e pawn but we can take
with the c pawn
black has to defend the knight with a
pawn
defending it with this pawn
or defending it with f5 leads to the
same response so let's say f5
now we simply play f3
again the knight is no squares all black
can try to do is attack this queen
counter attack in knight c6 but now
what is the most accurate move we just
step back to e3 and the knight is lost
amazingly although white has not
developed any pieces black actually
loses a piece and loses the game
all right
so
you might ask well what the hell is the
difference why would we even play queen
d4 it seems like this is just so much
easier
f5 f3 and he doesn't even have knight z6
so the problem is that black has e6
and the issue is that the knight escapes
the queen has to move
the knight moves away to g5 this is what
black didn't have in the other line
because the pawn was not on e6 and so
if you compare this position
to
um
to basically this position you'll see
that the g5 square is undefended by
playing e6 black creates a stronghold on
on g5
um
also queen h4 check is a possibility but
after knight g5 black is in good shape
um
the knight escapes via f7 if you attack
it one more time it comes back to f7 and
black is okay
um so the reason i'm taking some time on
this line is just to show you what
you know what you need to know at this
level it's like everything comes down to
these important details that can be
figured out with calculation
all right so he goes back to g8
knight f3
queen c7 and
queen to d5
defending both pawns at the same time
now why is e6 not scary
well um if you've watched the speedrun
in the past i often talk about
situations where black has gone g6 and
e6 at the same time
and the huge drawback of that is that
the d6 square becomes tremendously weak
that is why you have to be extremely
careful
about combining these two moves
um and i've shown many many times
the sort of illustrative game where i
learned my lesson the hard way even
though i won the game in the end
i once did e6 and g6 in the smith warren
i lost a rook in five moves
and if you look at this position after
queen takes pawn takes
this pawn is just completely burying
black's pieces white is and we're up
upon
if you want a refresher
as to
that game
have a look
this is a game from 20 2005.
um e4 c5 d4 it's a smith mora i didn't
really know how to play against it at
the time i had started the sicilian not
so long ago
not long before this game
so i figured i'd go g6 and fianchetto my
bishop luke's thank you for the prime
okay if you encounter it and after
castles i think the best move here is d6
and we get a theoretical position but i
played e6
because i had read that
there was this botvanic setup where you
put a bishop on g7 and a knight on e7
and that is indeed how you often play
against the close sicilian
so
if we examine for a second the close
sicilian
one of black's most reputable setups is
to play e6
you know whatever white generally plays
bishop b3 and then d6 and knight e7 i
figured i'd do the same thing
but what's the difference between the
two scenarios here the b the d6 square
is a lot more accessible to white's
pieces it's already controlled by the
queen
and now i play as knight b5 very typical
move
and there's no way to stop the knight
from coming to d6 i played knight f6 and
my opponent actually shocked me with an
even better move he goes queen into d6
and now knight c7 is simply unstoppable
so i had to go queen e7 and basically
give up the rook in the end game
somehow i managed to win this game i
managed to win this night
and my opponent just obviously butchered
it but
that was a
pretty good lesson i still like
the fact e6 and g6 isn't always bad but
you've got to be very careful about when
you play
now if you compare it obviously here the
queen doesn't control that square so a
move like knight p5 would be completely
useless you could play a6 or queen a5
check
it's all about understanding concretely
is this square accessible to white's
pieces if you're sure that it isn't then
it's okay to play these two modes
and i think a lot of you have probably
done this plenty of times okay
so
back to the game queen d5 knight c6
defend the pawn
and after f6 again at first i thought
this was winning
but then i realized he has knight takes
f6 and what kinds of things do you look
for in a position like this
when both queens are hanging at the same
time what do you need to look for
who can answer that question not not a
specific move but what type of move
two types of moves checks number one the
second is desperados and a desperado
doesn't necessarily have to be a check
you might just take a piece
now there is neither in this position
you could give a check but that's
useless
taking the knight would be something you
could look at but then the queen takes
the knight and that's obviously dumb
so
why did i play bishop c4 first because i
noticed the difference after bishop c4
e6 e takes f6
if black plays knight takes f6 let's do
that check again does white have any
checks or desperados
queen takes c6 there we go it's because
that pawn has appeared on e6
and now we are up actually two pawns and
black's pawn structure is destroyed now
you might look at this and say all of
this for just a pawn
but
you know that's better than nothing so
two pawns up in the end game you didn't
have the equivalent move had you not
played bishop c4
okay so that's what black should have
done i think that was the best that he
could manage in this position
but queen takes f4 happens and this just
loses the game very quickly f takes g7
and if black would have given a check
here we could have just covered with a
queen
actually quite important winning on the
spot
so he takes we take
and that's it
we're up a full rook and then knight on
jade is hanging
just to illustrate if we go bishop e2
after queen c1 bishop d1 queen takes b2
now i want to make it clear that white
is still completely winning here
all right and i remind you of a mistake
that boxbox made
when you make a blunder
i mean you can't allow yourself to
collapse you have to assess what the
damages and often the damage is not
going to be as severe as you thought it
was
um and this is a great example of that
remember that white is up a full rook so
in effect if you simply castle
and then you get the bishop out to b3 to
defend the knight you're still
completely winning look at black's king
if bishop takes d5 the queen is stranded
rookie one is coming
black can essentially resign so
even if you blunder like that
it's
yeah the point i was just gonna make is
that when you blunder
it's often you often blow it up in your
mind as like the end of the world
but
it's often not so even this would have
been winning but why allow it we play
bishop takes d5
and it's easy to establish queen c1 king
e2 if queen takes b2 we have knight bd2
connecting the rocks
um
and queen takes h1 bishop takes street
we're up a piece and we are mating him
so this is just over
any questions about this entire stretch
i want to make sure everybody was
following my calculations here
so i have a funny story about this um
i had this game where i did blunder a
fork and then realized that i'm
completely winning anyway
so
i have a funny funny example for you
okay so i played this game in 2011.
is us open
i'm obviously playing a much lower rated
opponent i'm completely winning i'm up
before exchange
and i got impatient
so
in this position after h3 king g5 i i
touch my rook
and i bring it to d5
and i'm like i haven't released my hand
yet and i realized that i was about to
blender 93 check now in over the board
chess
as long as you do not release a piece
you can move it to any other square you
can
bring it to d5 and then
you know as long as you haven't released
your hand you can bring it back to d3
but you have to move that rook you can
just move it elsewhere
but then i decided that i could just
leave it there because even after knight
e3
it's very easy to establish that this
pawn end game is completely winning i'm
just up a pawn
um and you know i'm just gonna create a
passer on the other side of the board so
it's the game is over and he actually
resigned here
um so
you know don't panic the reaction to a
blunder shouldn't be panic it should
just be soberly evaluating
the damage
um
and that's all she wrote happy accident
is right
boom boom boom and the last thing i'll
say here is that
yeah there are many ways to win this
game but we decided to bring the queen
to
diego knight g5 and if king e8
um the computer shows a very pretty
force
mate um the engine shows a really cool
mate so what do we want here
again one good way of thinking about
this is
to understand what the target position
is well the target position is this very
same position
if the king was on d8 then we'd have the
familiar mate right so what we can
actually do is triangulate our queen
in such a way that forces the king back
to d8
how did we get the king to d8 in the
first place
well we gave a check on d6 so if we
could repeat this position with the
knight on g5 would be mate right well it
turns out that we can
it turns out that we can we go queen e5
check
okay king
f8 if king d8 then it's an immediate
checkmate on f7
king f8
now we give a check on f6 obviously king
g8 queen f7 is an easy mate king e8
check and that's it we've gotten the
same position that we just got except
the knight is on g5 check
check
check
checkmate so if you look at this without
understanding the logic it seems
impossible to find but
when you deconstruct the logic it
becomes pretty straightforward
it's a really cool pattern though just
using the queen to force basically get
the king where you want it to be
what might have been the plan to get the
queen side out of out if there hadn't
been a way to just made him great
question so let's imagine for a second
that there was no mate
let's rewind all the way to this
position let's say we didn't see the
mate what would be the plan
well um
you could approach this in two ways the
first would be to try to get rid of the
queen so one thing you could do here is
go queen d4
and then get the queen to d1 to force
black's queen out of the first rank and
as soon as the queen leaves the first
rank you can develop the knight and
consolidate
the second approach
is to prepare knight bd2 and basically
say i'm going to let the queen remain on
h1 this is worse
than the first plan but it also works
you can go
c4
and then on the next move you go b3 you
connect the queen and the rook
and then you can get your knight out to
d2 now actually both of those are fine
[Music]